bonsoir nicola sirkis merci d'être avec
nous c'est une exclusivité france 2 car
vous êtes plutôt rare à la télévision
on parlera du nouvel album d'indochine
dans un instant mais d'abord vous avez
suivi la cérémonie
le seuil est hier soir les bus à lherm h
au houga l'instant qu'est ce que vous
avez ressenti beaucoup d'émotions en
plus pour tous pour lui pour sa famille
et où toute l'équipe qui travaille avec
lui qui sont assez lentement se trouve
donc c'était très émouvant
alors on va parler de vous maintenant et
d'indochine pas facile de résumer 30 ans
de carrière en quelques minutes dans ces
cas-là faut faire simple de dissidence
politique à la république des météores
retour avec bruno le dreff et matières
rouleront sur la carrière d'un groupe à
la longévité jamais égalée en france le
phénomène dure depuis près de 30 ans 30
en quelques courtes à la rencontre de
nicolas s escon sirkis bien sûr monsieur
sirkis voici d'ailleurs votre première
télé un an à peine après la création
d'un office
ils sont
viennent ensuite les années
psychédéliques à son équipe en forme que
ça marche
le troisième disque d'or d'indochine
pour leur 3e vice amplement méritée
parce que c'est un groupe formidable
années 80 années indochine
le groupe enchaîne les succès plus de
deux millions d'albums vendus en dix ans
après les pyjamas nicolas peut s'offrir
deux jolies pu dans la machine après une
période difficile un album si fort mal
leur maison de disques qui les virent
une partie des membres qui s'en va le
xxième siècle sera indochine ou ne sera
pas
les titres emplissent les gorges et
résonne dans les oreilles
nicolas se met à nu et le public aime ça
le prochain album est en route le single
déjà à l'antenne
nicola sirkis et c'est bizarre c'est
particulier de voir un condensé de sa
carrière comme ça en moins de deux
minutes
oui oui j'avais pas vu ces images depuis
un bout de temps et ouais ça c'est
bizarre la république des météores sort
le 9 mars un mot du titre république des
météores dans l'une de vos chansons
république à vous dites on sera
républicain de loin vous pouvez
expliquer c'est une façon de dire qu'on
appartient un peu tout ça cette sorte de
république là que vous exposez dans les
journaux et que et qu'on n'est pas dupe
il faut pas être trop dupes bible de
quoi bad dudes des mensonges la crise
qu'on vit aujourd'hui par exemple elle
est uniquement basée sur des mensonges
sur les gens qui ont travaillé les ou
l'autre et c'est donc il faut pas être
dupe républicain de loin restons polis
mais de loin à propos vous parlez aussi
vous dites que vous avez du mal avec les
artistes et particulièrement avec les
artistes qui habite en suisse qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire oui enfin c'est en
fait foi sont sur cette chanson je dis
aussi autre chose que j'ai mis les
vêtements de ma mère que je suis un cas
désespéré mais non mais j'ai été un peu
choqué effectivement le jour de
l'élection du nouveau président la
république en france que deux ou trois
artistes qui l'ont félicité en premier
soit des exilés fiscaux
ça m'a un petit peu dérangé alors la
république des météores c'est
probablement ce pas une formule
marketing mais l'album le plus attendu
d'indochine est ce que vous savez
pourquoi il ya une telle attente mais je
sais pas c'est vrai que c'est
curieusement c'est l'album qui suscite
le plus d'interrogations le plus
d'attentes depuis qu'on a annoncé la fin
de son enregistrement est à peu près
quelques mois il méga attendu donc la
mega mega peur mais bon on reste
confiant c'est ça va mais gars bien se
passer non à ben j'en sais rien on verra
ça vole dans une semaine est-ce qu à l
inverse
vous avez une idée de la raison pour
laquelle louis où il ya eu un vrai creux
de vague dans les années 90 je trouve
que c'est un peu normal qu'en fait quand
on a une trentaine d'années là comme ça
enfin là on est à 28 29 ans mais que au
moment de noël les gens il en a un peu
marre aussi
on essaie de se faire discret et puis
après c'est dire que des retours de
bâton des choses comme ça je trouve ça
un petit peu normal après moi j'ai
trouvé ça que j'ai trouvé que c'était un
petit peu injuste parfois surface dur
assure des critiques des choses comme ça
ce que c'est que de la musique quoi donc
on ça méritait pas non plus une sorte de
charges comme ça mais ça fait du bien
aussi la mort de votre frère jumeau
qu'on a revu dans le sujet de bruno le
dreff stéphane lhomme fondateur du
groupe avec vous remonte à dix ans
quasiment jour pour jour il ya un livre
qui vient de paraître
écrit par votre autre frère un livre qui
est très dur contre vous est ce que vous
l'avez lu non mais je moi je crois
savoir qu'il ya à peu près 3 4 livres
qui sortent en ce moment sur sur nous je
les ai pas lues personne nous a proposé
d'ailleurs de l'est de les lire
et là dedans choc il ya il ya des
marchands de mort il ya des marchands de
vie moi j'ai choisi la vie je voudrais
plus de m'étaler là-dessus un dernier
mot pour finir qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ses 30 ans de carrière
longévité record pour un groupe français
la vie merci beaucoup de nicola sirkis